there's a trucking problem in the us
right now businesses are saying there's
a shortage of drivers caused by well a
whole host of reasons but it's resulting
in empty shelves in some supermarkets to
solve the shortage one group estimates
that the industry needs to hire an
additional 80 000 drivers but at the
same time autonomous trucking companies
like aurora and embark are saying that
their driver less technology is right
around the corner and could even get
here before fully autonomous taxes i
think that autonomous trucking has a
much clearer path to market both
technically and as a commercial product
we're working to launch the product
commercially at the end of 23. so could
driverless trucks arrive in time to
solve the truck driver shortage and
could they eliminate the need for truck
drivers all together
to get a better idea of how the
technology may fit into the market i
caught up with aurora and embark in
early november as the companies were
making their stock market debut let's
get into it
[Music]
first i want to demonstrate why you
might see a fully autonomous truck on
the highway before you see a fully
driverless taxi in the street and that's
partly because highway driving can be
less complex than inner city driving in
the city i have to constantly indicate
look left look right accelerate mine
that bike check mirrors watch that car
break watch out for that ma'am
but on the highway
life can be a little bit simpler
what makes it easier is that you're able
to tackle those problems in a much more
structured setting if you think about a
mile of freeway in texas versus a mile
of freeway in arizona the traffic on it
mostly behaves the same way whereas in
urban driving when you go from one block
in san francisco to five blocks away
from there the traffic can look very
different and behave very differently
driverless trucks also don't have to
convince paying passengers that the
vehicle is safe enough to hop on board
but i'm not saying truck driving is easy
i've been speaking to my colleague
jennifer smith who covers logistics
about some of the challenges that
autonomous truck driving faces the idea
of a truck a big rig
loaded with freight with no driver
behind the wheel hurtling down the road
at 55 plus miles per hour can tend to
give people pause aurora and embark told
me that safety is a big part of the
reason why their technology is yet to be
released into the wild you need to have
all those pieces running together and
reliability tested the companies have
been racking up test miles though by
operating a fleet of trucks with support
drivers along highways even if these
companies can demonstrate that their
autonomous trucks are safe right now u.s
states aren't aligned over how those
trucks can operate regulations are a bit
of a patchwork in in the us different
states allow different things so it's
possible to to sort of cobble together a
route that you could haul freight on a
lot of folks are hauling freight in
between arizona and texas if we had a
truck that we were confident in the
safety of we believe we could launch
that in 45 of the 50 u.s states in order
for these autonomous trucks to travel
across america they'll need alignment
across the states in which they travel
through one of the things we look
forward to is seeing the state by state
rules start to harmonize but that's not
all separately there's the issue of how
federal highway safety regulators will
be treating this until these companies
figure out those legislative and safety
hurdles it's unlikely that they'll make
much of an impact on the current u.s
truck driver shortage but what about
when they do solve those challenges what
does that mean for non-autonomous truck
drivers
you know the human ones well to begin
with autonomous trucks could take over
long-haul routes which often present the
most grueling conditions for drivers
you're spending a lot of time on the
road away from home and you're basically
living in a tin can that's smaller than
a suburban bathroom operating
autonomously from hub to hub could also
redefine what a driver's normal
day-to-day looks like maybe this driver
could handle shorter runs and get home
more often we turn it into a job where
you work a regular shift and then you go
home to your family but as aurora say
they plan to take on shorter routes in
the future are those drivers still going
to be able to find work in the long term
well
it's likely the bulk of u.s trucking is
made of a fragmented market of smaller
fleets with low margins so even if robo
trucks do appear on the highways
carriers will still have to be able to
afford them so the sheer demand for
truck drivers and goods on our shelves
means that in the future it's likely
that man and machine will both have a
role to play
hey autonomous trucks may be a few years
away but if you want to know what's
happening with truck drivers right now
check out this video made by my
colleagues emma scott and todd johnson
i've left the link below and as always
if you're interested in the future of
how we might be getting from a to b then
don't forget to subscribe see you later
[Music]
you